I told you before our vacation last week that
our friend JD Scholten is once again challenging
incumbent, disgusting Republican Steve King
and Iowa's fourth district in 2020 we met
JD Scholten down at netroots nation in August
of 2018 he ran against JD against Steve King
in 2018 and lost by only three points. Very
sad because it would have been amazing to
knock off one of the most and despicable members
of congress. A king is in trouble and j d
Scholten is running a king has said crazy
things about abortion.
King has reminisced about when white supremacy
and white nationalism weren't offensive, saying
to the New York Times during an interview,
white nationalist white supremacist civilization.
How did that language become offensive? But
king is in trouble. Republicans have abandoned
him and he has almost no money. This is so
funny. King hasn't received one donation from
a PAC associated with an existing member of
Congress. This is a common way that these
guys fund each other. Corporate pacs aren't
donating to Steve King. Special interest groups
aren't donating to Steve King. In the first
six months of this year, King received two,
two donations from third party political entities.
One was from Lamar Smith, uh, an uh, a Lamar
Smith associated pack, former Republican congressman,
and $2,000 from Todd Akin. Todd Akin is the
guy who said that the body shuts down a legitimate
rape and thus the woman can't get pregnant.
That guy is saying, I want to donate $2,000
to Steve King.
Republican party groups are also not donating,
so this guy can be defeated. Think back to
2018 j d Scholten lost by only three points
in 2016, I'm sorry, 2018 back when Steve King
was still able to raise money. This guy, Steve
King, is someone who came to power as a tool
of big business. Quite frankly, he came to
power because the bankers gave him money.
He came to power because big builders and
companies like a t and t and big food gave
him money. Big Insurance gave Steve King money.
They're not giving them money this year and
that's really, really bad for Steve King.
So as usual, there's the good and the bad.
The good news is that without money he can
more easily lose to j d Scholten the bad,
or at least the troubling part is how did
it take until 2020 to realize for Republicans
that they need to abandon this guy?
And the answer is they don't really care.
They're playing now like they're, oh, they're
so disgusted with the things that Steve King
has said. No, this is the same Steve King
that's been around all along. And while this
wasn't a problem for them, king was another
vote in the house and that's why they wanted
it. It's not that he was, uh, someone that
they disagreed with or agreed with or whatever.
They were indifferent. They just want someone
to check a box and say, yes, I'll vote Republican.
Now he's become a PR problem. So they're abandoning
him. Let's not attribute to morality and ethics,
what we can attribute merely to Republican
seeing politics of sport wins and losses,
checking boxes and that's it. But he needs
to go. Hopefully he will in 2020 check out
JD Shelton's campaign. JT is a former professional
baseball player. Super Nice Guy. Hung out
with him, uh, in in 2018 in New Orleans. As
I mentioned, he came so close in 2018 with
the loss of Steve King's funding and the abandonment
that Steve King is suffering from his Republican
party colleagues. This could be an amazing
time to get a Democrat in the Iowa fourth
congressional district. Check it out, check
out JD Scholten and hopefully we'll be talking
to him on the program. We'll take a quick
break after this. We have extraordinarily
great submissions
for the David Pakman show, EDM Dubstep, voicemail
remix theme song. If you have no idea what
I'm talking about, uh, then I think you're
going to like it even more.